У цьому сезоні агрономи очікують, що лохина через холодну погоду дозріє пізніше.
Розраховують не менш ніж на тонну з гектара.
Уже через кілька тижнів треба буде наймати
не менше 100-150 працівників на збирання ягід.
За спостереженням агронома Юрія Белалова,
щороку людей, які надають перевагу сезонним заробіткам в Україні,
а не за кордоном, стає дедалі більше.
У цьому сезоні в нас одна людина, яка працювала
торік у Польщі на такому ж господарстві,  навіть більшому.
Минулого року було декілька людей,  які працювали
не тільки в Польщі, а й у інших країнах.
І всі вони були задоволені роботою в нас.
У цьому сезоні через закриті через коронавірус кордони
таких охочих стало ще більше.
Телефони багатьох господарств не затихають останніми місяцями,
особливо тепер, перед початком збору ягід.
Навіть цілі бригади телефонують через те, що не хочуть виїжджати в Польщу.
Бо нині і важко виїхати,
і переїзд за кодон, я знаю по знайомих, набагато дорожчий, ніж раніше.
В  цьому році я сама планувала їхати до Німеччини,
але в зв’язку з ситуацією в світі, в Україні,
я вирішила працювати на території України, неподалік від дому.
Житомирщина поступово перетворюється на такий собі ягідний кластер.
Тут є кілька господарств, які вирощують лохину, жимолость, полуницю, малину,
приймають лісову чорницю від населення на продаж тощо.
Проте поки що вони не мають стільки врожаю,
щоб скласти конкуренцію тим же польським виробництвам, де задіяні тисячі робітників.
Але ситуація поволі змінюється.
З кожним роком кількість людей, які потрібні нам,
збільшується в геометричній прогресії.
Кожен рік ми вдвічі більше збираємо ягід, ніж у попередні.
І саме така ситуація відбувається не тільки в нас,
а й на багатьох інших господарствах, які були засновані останні  3-5 років.
Найближчим часом Україну очікує
бум з точки зору лохини, кількості зібраної ягоди.
За даними асоціації "Ягідництво України",
українські господарства дійсно активно розвиваються
і щонайменше останні 3 роки відчувають дефіцит робочої сили.
В Україні є вже господарства, які мають великі площі, приміром, 600 гектарів.
А це означає, що щодня тут потрібні щонайменше півтисячі робітників.
Великі і середні компанії вимушені постійно збільшувати оплату праці,
стверджують в асоціації "Ягідництво України".
Якщо позаминулого сезону
зарплати складали десь у середньому
300-400 гривень на день,
то минулого це було вже 700-800.
Тобто за рік вони зросли вдвічі.
У цьому сезоні, прогнозують в асоціації,
середній рівень оплати робіт зі збору ягід може становити
1000-1200 гривень щоденно.
Якщо узяти збирання лохини, а цього року кілограм коштує 12 гривень,
то заробити ці гроші можна, здавши 100 кілограмів ягід.
Якщо буде цей рік ягода,
можна за день 100 кілограмів назбирати. Це я за себе - точно назбираю.
У Польщі Світлана за 100 кілограмів заробила би десь удвічі більше.
Проте жінка не хоче кидати своїх дітей та родину, витрачатися на переїзд,
мати купу додаткових витрат.
Каже, умови праці в Україні її теж цілком влаштовують.
Зміна з 8-ої до 17-ої.
Щогодини 10-хвилинна перерва.
Перерва на обід. Обабіч поля стоять туалети,
є все необхідне для гігієни.
Додому і на роботу працівників безкоштовно доправляють спеціальним автобусом.
Світлана, у якої двоє дітей, навіть і чоловіка свого сюди залучила.
Віталій втратив роботу водія автобуса через карантин.
І подружжя вирішило далеко на заробітки не їхати.
Влаштовує, раз прийшов.
Кудись їхати, щось шукати - краще на місці працювати.
На в’їзді в селище Раковичі стоїть ось цей банер.
Селяни можуть непогано заробляти у себе вдома.
Виконувач обов’язків старости села Олександр Марчук мріє саме про це:
аби селяни працездатного віку не їхали ні до Києва, ні за кордон.
Ще рік-два - і в нас будуть заробітні плати, як за кордоном.
Тому що таким підприємствам, які створюються, їм потрібні робочі місця
Іде війна за робочі руки,
і підприємці будуть вимушені
наймати людей за такі гроші, як за кордоном.
Можливо, трохи менше, бо там
розраховано за кордоном на те, що людина платить
і за житло, і за харчування, і за підвіз,
І те, що далеко від сім’ї, - це компенсується
А в нас тут все на місці, все під боком.
Наразі більш-менш привабливі умови для сезонних заробітків
можуть запропонувати лише великі аграрні підприємства, орієнтовані на експорт.
Таких в Україні поки не так багато.
Як вважають в асоціації "Ягідництво України",
аби заробІтки європейського рівня стали реальністю в усіх ягідних господарствах,
треба впроваджувати геть іншу державну політику:
дотувати аграріїв і давати їм не позики під 18%,
а справді дешеві, як у ЄС кредити - 3-4%.
Більшість ягід на внутрішньому ринку України -
це продукція не офіційно створених господарств.
Це те, що селяни приватно виростили на своїх городах,
або ягоди, зібрані у лісах.
Усе це продається "по-чорному" за низькими цінами перекупникам,
фермерам, дещо потрапляє на ринок.
На думку представниці Української плодоовочевої асоціації Катерини Звєрєвої,
держава лише виграла б, якби дозволила селянам продавати свої ягоди та фрукти
за спрощеною процедурою - приміром, за паспортом і без податків, як у Молдові.
А господарствам, які цю продукцію купують, знизити оподаткування.
Це все тінь.
У нас 90% плодоовочівництва - в тіні.
Саме з тієї причини, що податки
для бізнесу плодоовочевого - досить високі.
Саме тому одним з рішень було б
зниження ставки ПДВ
хоча б до 8-10% у плодоовочевому бізнесі.
На думку Звєрєвої, це мотивувало б селян не їхати за кордон,
а ставати самому  собі підприємцем на своїх паях
і заробляти стільки ж, як на полях ЄС.
Люди, які виїжджають на заробітки до європейських країн,
це скарб України.
Тому що ці люди не тільки заробляють гроші,
які потім вони можуть інвестувати в Україну,
у створення тут власних господарств за європейським зразком.
Але це люди, які навчаються
сучасним технологіям вирощування
і реалізації плодоовочевої продукції.
Наразі знайти кваліфікований персонал - важко, кажуть у господарстві "Нікдарія".
Лише нещодавно тут вдалося знайти помічника агронома, який раніше працював у Польщі.
Тепер шукають гідротехніка, який міг би керувати сучасними зрошувальними системами.
Потрібні ще кваліфіковані робітники для роботи з різною сільськогосподарською технікою,
у морозильному цеху.
Представники галузі думають над тим, як запропонувати людям роботу на цілий сезон.
Приміром, починати залучати робітників ще з травня, на збір спаржі.
Спаржу треба збирати двічі на день.
Кінець сезону, я відламую...
Скуштуйте. Я кажу: смачно.
А далі залучати їх у збір ягід у червні-липні і, можливо, садити щось нове,
щоб люди могли працювати до початку осені.
Також слід подбати про гуртожитки для робітників.
Лише тоді, каже підприємець, можна буде говорити про те,
що сезонна робота в Україні стане більш привабливою, ніж на чужині.